[Music]
all right Ariana hey Ariana where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
Long Beach Long Beach
both your parents growing up yeah I did
I had a good life
a good childhood I should say
how would you describe to your childhood
could I have my mom my dad grandma
siblings
yeah we were close
very no traumatic events in your
childhood
you know that's the cool part about it
though I just wanted to experiment
and your experiment LED you
at what age did that happen
12. 12 years old
I want it to be grown
you grow fast yes I want it to be grown
did you see girls working the street
when you were a kid no
I didn't but I heard about it I wanted
to be grown and
easy money
very easily do you recall your first
time as a 12 year old doing this do you
recall your very first time doing this
as a 12 year old
tell me about it
I wanted some Jordans so I went to
Sunset and I met my first trick and we
went to a motel we dated it was cool he
gave me 150 I got my Jordans in the
window in the house
were you sexually active before that of
course of course
yes I was I mean did you eventually hook
up with the pimp of yet of course the 12
year old I guess doesn't do this on her
own of course yes I did I had a couple
pimps in my knees
yes
how would you describe those
relationships
hectic abusive
something I would never get back into
I just couldn't do it again
very abusive
very
how old are you now 28 28.
do you have kids tattoo
four four kids four
are you raising them yeah
I have one in the car with my mom right
now oh is that right yes outside
yes
and you're still working what can't you
tell obviously yes but uh
mom and kids know what you're doing you
see in the car yeah bury myself I'm
grown
if you don't like it but she can't
change it so
tell me about how this lifestyle affects
you emotionally
ah
I don't got no emotions no more it just
killed all my emotions
I really don't have none
a sex drive gone it just killed
everything
honestly yeah
is there any sexual abuse in your
childhood no nothing like that
but as I've been doing this so long my
sex drive is gone not saying I don't
like to [ __ ] or bust nuts but it's just
gone so working as a prostitute at 12
years old is some form of abuse I think
you've had bad experiences out there
you've had bad experiences of course
what kind of stuff getting raped yeah
you know but you gotta
of course you gotta roll with it keep
going can't let it Knock You Down
how do you think the years of doing this
have changed you
I don't know my mindset is set on this
so I think it's going to be very hard
for me to take my mindset out of this I
went to something else are you addicted
to this fast money
lifestyle there's no other hustle that
can match this money right no and for me
to be doing this so young this is all I
know so it's like
right now no okay nothing man somebody
said you know quit doing this and and
get a square job that was that would
scare you
I wouldn't even know how to go about it
I wouldn't even know the first step of
doing that
you have daughters and one are you
worried about the role model that you're
I tell them a dresser up like a Muslim
she'll come out the house I have to
cover from head to toe
yeah
tell me about the guys who pick you up
your customers
they're cool I mean some of them could
be [ __ ] but they're cool for the
most part give them what they want they
give me what I want go about our way
what have you learned about men what
have you learned about men from doing
this
oh they're so conniving they are so
conniving
you guys are so conniving do a lot of
them have Secret Lives from there yes
they marry yes very you would be very
surprised
very surprised
the customers that we get
and you live in an apartment or hotels
apartment
me my dude and my kids
have you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
this
honestly because this I wouldn't know I
wouldn't no I wouldn't have been doing
this no I would have changed this I
would have stayed in school
you know
but
let's see I would have changed this I
wouldn't have
you believe in karma like a [ __ ]
how does karma play out in your life
I'll try to walk a nice you know I don't
try to play nobody because I man I walk
the streets every day so somebody you
know I'm bound to bump into somebody so
I try not to go that route
unless necessary but
I want to stay on a nice you know you be
cool with me I'm cool with you
you've been in love before have you been
in love before of course yeah I'm in
love now yeah
and he tolerates this lifestyle yeah not
yeah
you're doing it just to pay the bills
pretty much
it's not a long term eventually I'll
stop but not now
how does this job affect your confidence
your self-esteem oh I'm bomb
bomb they don't knock it off it a bomb
regardless
myself anyway
very much so
what advice would you give to a woman
who's thinking about doing this kind of
work don't do it no
no don't do it
do not do it
not every woman can do it right
yeah
dangerous
what do you think most squares don't
understand about girls that do this kind
of work
they're haters I can't stand them I
really don't they don't see that they
think that we're just nasty we are here
[ __ ] that ain't even the case though
you know we paying bills like they are
but I cannot stand there
they're [ __ ] more men than we are and
they're so worried about what we're
doing police we're getting paid for it
they lay down broke wake up broke
so I don't see how they complain so much
are drugs a part of your life
weed yeah
is it difficult to
operate in a
little subculture where everyone's like
on the take everyone's dishonest
yeah
sort of
yes the other girls the tricks the even
the cops sometimes man them all the time
you think you deserve a better life than
this
I pray on it every day I just made a bad
decision when you were 12.
I pray on it
what's more important do you love our
money
whoa
money
because I can love you and we're gonna
be broke in the tent nothing gonna get
us nowhere
money yeah
do you get risky requests from some of
your clients
if I mean you they didn't want to use a
condo but that's just something I'm not
doing yeah that's mostly the number one
thing
it's a dangerous job you worry about
going out there and having your kids at
home every day
every day you gotta be extra careful
what do you use your intuition must be
very heightened right yeah I mean you
know I got my car and yeah I've been
doing it for a long time when a guy
rolls up to pick you up do you quickly
assess whether he's make sure to hit the
police of course and to take them to a
room most likely or we do it in a car
whatever he picked
Ariana what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life
don't grow up too fast
I should have stayed you know a kid and
worked my way up don't grow up too fast
honestly
you feel like you missed missed out on
your childhood did I yes I don't feel
like it I did for sure
a lot of [ __ ] I have never done
just because of this job
all right Ariana thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
and your kids lots of luck thank you
thank you